anything so if you if women get the law
say in during intercourse do you think
women should get the last say when it
comes to if they have an abortion or not
see I've spoken about this a lot I don't
I think it might show up on that one
that was actually my next question yeah
like serious it is um I think that the
that
if the the partner has an issue I think
if the woman says I want an abortion and
the boyfriend is like I don't want an
abortion
then I would say for the woman to go and
do it that's
okay but what if they both agreed to
have an abortion and then the woman
decides okay I'm gonna keep the baby now
I know many of those
issue wrong for the women is she wrong I
think uh
well you know what's interesting women
have the right not to be mothers but men
don't have the right not to be fathers
because a woman could get an abortion
and say I don't want to be a mother but
a man can't opt out of Child Support or
he goes to jail or gets his assets
seized yeah yeah that's not in that
angle the way how you pass out yeah
then you're complaining that some people
are pro-life you can't really have a
complaint from both sides if you're
pro-life Then You're Gonna Want women to
do that right you can't criticize women
for both things no no I actually I would
ban child support actually yeah yeah
yeah I would say I would say I would say
I make supports for the church yeah well
I would if women were just if women were
really just spending child support on
the child I might support that but yeah
and and
500 I mean maybe you make a lot of money
you're an internet person you know but
for the average guy that's a lot in a
month 500 bucks a month but you think
that's a lot for sustaining a child I
mean I think I think I think if you can
afford the child you should have custody
of it so if she can't afford the child
give it to the dad the reason that the
dad can't afford it is because he's at
work all the time and how can you look
after a kid with you guys well that's my
point it should be his responsibility so
if he wants to let the mom watch it when
he wants her
thing right you can fight for sure it's
really not a thing here it's it's they
only get custody 10 of the time so 50
50. well the reason they don't is
because they go broke doing it and a lot
of them a lot of lawyers advise them not
to I mean I've interviewed guys that
like go through this it's not an easy
process I I think the reality is it's
very hard to sustain that because if
you're a man and you're working
full-time it's not worth to fight it
unless you're willing to work less or
lose your job or do a different job like
so when you're looking at it from this
perspective one of the two has to work
and if you're the one with the better
job you're going to opt out of that as a
choice well I just don't think you
should be rewarded for making a poor
choice so I think you know if you can if
you can let's listen to me and not make
it a kid let's make it a dog if I can
afford a dog then I get the dog why why
should you why should you get the kid if
you can't afford it and it's like it's
like it's almost like it's almost like
it's almost like punishing men for doing
the right thing they're supposed to work
they're doing the right thing and now
we're punishing them and saying no you
can't have the kid because you're
working but a kid needs more than just
money right you need to be it's the
caring okay okay well then if we're
gonna put the kid first then the Dad
should definitely get it because single
father homes produce better children
than single mother homes thank you
is so right because the men that do take
it on have the capabilities to be there
I mean I mean that's the reason that
they're usually really rich that's the
reason that the left gives but you just
said it's not about money and now you're
saying it's money because if you already
have the money then you don't have to
work
all right so that's that's not true
there's good Rich parents there's good
poor parents
that's not the same I think she likes to
conflict a lot of things I don't think
most of the fathers that raise their
kids on their own are rich I actually
think it's the opposite because more
time more often than not if uh if a man
is rich he can have the mother take care
of the kid the mother doesn't have to
work he doesn't have to be with her
that's what would usually happen
being a man knowing a lot of men are in
that situation I know that's what
usually happened most of the men that
raise kids on their own are struggling
of course it's a struggle for both
women as well
equal so it's like if we my whole point
is it's not equal so it's like okay if
we if if the feminists the left would
ever want abortion to be legal then then
why then then let the men not be fathers
too the thing is I'm not too sure like
honestly I'm not I'd really like to know
the type of men that you're speaking
about because the women that I know
of whether I know of them personally I
mean they're single mothers like they're
begging their father they're begging
their baby father for money towards like
summer camp for the kids because these
dads think that their the mother's whole
life should revolve around the children
when he does the bare minimum like I
said before why can't she have a life
it's like one of these men why did she
why did she open her legs for him my
thing is women have all the choice when
it comes to sex it is not hard for us to
get sex but this is why everyone
abortion every every half attractive
chick has five dudes and her friends on
the chicken date can I can I ask can I
ask what's your opinion on Grape then
like if it's not in the women's control
what do you then think grape grape is a
bit irritating people always bring this
up and it because it's less than point
five percent of abortion but it doesn't
so you're right I'll tell you my opinion
but I'm saying if you know it's
frustrating because it's like okay if we
give you grape will you guys get rid of
the 99.5 of abortions and I know the
answer to that is no so I just think
people do that as a way to discredit the
right but
um no great I would have no exceptions
what your guys views on
um say a girl
says that she's on contraception
but then
um and then the guy doesn't use a condom
oh wait actually no sorry did use a
condom and the girl holes
huh poke holes in it is that what you're
getting that turkey baster
y
yes okay are you gonna so what what is
so for the dad who is now a dad and he
didn't want to be a dad and he asked and
made sure are you on contraception yes
okay and they still put our condom on
and she's poked holes or turkey-based
dude
um you know that kind of thing what and
and and as people say trapped their dad
and then he is not a great dad
but then she trapped him I mean you know
what I was thinking about I was thinking
about how they make laws where if a guy
removes the condom without a woman's
consent that's considered grape yet a
woman lying to a man about birth control
is not considered
so that's what I was that's serious that
is an actual thing if you interfere with
the condom it is a crime but it's but
it's important to prove so it is but you
would agree that's a double standard
right yeah that is a double standard 100
because
yeah not today but they're both primes
no no but I'm asking would you say it's
a double stand it's not a crime for a
woman to do that the birth control is
not a crime lying about birth control
well yeah that that's not an unethical
but you shouldn't just blindly believe I
mean you were the one criticizing you do
you think do you think that's a double
standard that's my question please no I
think it's stupidity on the men's part
okay so this is somebody okay even if
they're dating them like this is a lot
of times this happens to men that have
been well it's a multi-year it's
unethical it's deceptive it's
manipulative but you probably shouldn't
be dating someone like that right to the
women like you shouldn't be dating
someone people shouldn't date bad people
if you're saying it's it's a crime if
the guy if if they got both crimes okay
but you you know I said one was a crime
one is that well you said you kind of
defended the other one you kind of gave
the woman the out again but my point is
if the guy's own is bad for taking off
the condom you said it can be proved if
the woman interferes with the condom so
how does the woman prove that the guy
took off the condom after the fact I
think he
um well it is it's incredibly hard to
prove but if there is semen inside the
woman then she can go get checked to the
hospital
there's a condom and now there's not a
condom no no it's hard to convict for
sexual assault in general so you can't
prove it because when you're going to
prove it you're not going to be how did
the condom get off you're not listening
if she's going to have to go and prove
it then she has to bring evidence
does matter so if you imagine not having
sex with somebody and they've got you in
say a particular position where you
can't see them for example they're not
face to face now
um you have now stopped having sex you
guys have intercourse sorry I don't even
know if I can really say that can I say
that yeah yeah so you guys are having
you guys are finished doing what you're
doing and obviously he's released you've
released climax or whatever you realize
he's not wearing a condom now there's
only two things there's only two ways
that can go it's either the condom has
slipped off inside of you
or the condom has come off and how's the
condom gonna magically come arguing with
that I know but I'm saying like but if
they've taken a condom off then that's
the pre-frame
she said that the guy won't be able to
prove that the woman interfered with the
condom okay agreed I thought it would be
hard you kind of candles
let him finish okay
hard to prove that the woman interfere
with the condom I think it's equally as
hard to prove that the man took of the
condom because how do you sh how do you
prove to the Lord that okay this man
took off the condom because semen is not
proof because there are people that have
gotten pregnant even when the condom was
still on yeah so when a guy takes off a
condom
and it's got semen inside of it if there
was a hole in the condom wouldn't you
notice that
it's like the Siemens coming out of the
condom when you see a hole like it's
seeping through or something when you
notice that so when you're putting a
condom on maybe maybe I can't believe it
okay but I think that works just off the
back of what you've said I think I've
just clocked it that would prove it so
so for example if she kept the condom as
evidence and there was holes in the
condo in all honesty then maybe it was
no there's no good can I finish there no
there's no good way to prove it no
there's no there's no goodness
you can prove it this is this is like
this is how in my opinion a lot of false
accusations come because there's no
really good way to prove this stuff
because well yeah but it's still going
to be he said she said no no it's not
your consent no because if she's kept
the condom if she kept the condom and
there's no holes in it let me let me
land how would they know it was
consensual or not oh let me know I let
you talk a lot all right but I haven't
landed though if the condom has got no
holes or no splits or nothing in it and
she's pregnant it would surely show that
the condom had to have been physically
removed if there was holes or or gaps in
a condom then maybe it was very simple
but you still wouldn't know if she
consented to it being removed or not no
you wouldn't so exactly I'm only going
off that's my point so it goes back if
he said she said it's only two people in
a room unless there's cameras correct as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible